okay well good afternoon everyone and
welcome to the Thursday October 17 2019
session in our series on edge computing
whether there will be different
directions for Asia and the United
States or not
I'm Richard Asher I direct the u.s. Asia
Technology Management Center at Stanford
we're very happy to produce this series
and we want to thank all of our member
companies for support of our series as
well as support of our other activities
and please stay afterward and have some
refreshments outside with us get to meet
our speakers also get to meet
representatives of our member companies
I'm very happy that today we're moving
into actual use cases of edge computing
so we started off I gave an overview at
the end of September we had a
presentation on 5g we had a presentation
on chip acceleration last week so for
this week we're going to talk about a
very important use case where a large
amount of the information processing has
to happen at the edge device meaning in
this case the automobile we're going to
talk about self-driving cars today I
have with us a great panel so closest to
me is dr. Sven biker and I've known spin
for years then was the executive
director of the cars lab at Stanford the
Center for Automotive Research at
Stanford however since then he's been an
expert on mobility topics at McKinsey
and company and most recently he's the
founding managing director of Silicon
Valley mobility which is a consultancy
and advisory firm before he came to
Stanford he worked for the BMW group for
13 years and he has worked in Silicon
Valley in Germany and in Detroit and he
received his master's and PhD degrees in
mechanical engineering from the
Technical University in Braunschweig
Germany he's published various technical
papers and holds several patents in the
area of vehicle dynamics and powertrain
and further away from me is dr. Martin
Cirrus and Martin is the chief
technology officer of what's now called
the Alliance Innovation Lab in Silicon
Valley now this was originally the
Nissan Research Center of Silicon Valley
and Martin was the founding director he
also established their research agenda
including leading a team of researchers
on artificial intelligence technologies
for automotive vehicles connected
vehicles and human machine interaction
also he spent before he came to Nissan
he spent 12 years at NASA Ames working
on human and autonomy systems for Space
Exploration
so not only how to have an autonomous
satellite but how to automate the work
of flight controllers in NASA mission
control so he has a long term career in
research and software engineering he has
worked at the Palo Alto Research Center
at nine x science and technology at IBM
corporation and he's an entrepreneur he
founded the startup company agenda so we
will ask spin to give some comments then
we'll ask Martin to give some comments
than all three of us will come up here
and have a real panel discussion so in
the floor is yours that great thanks so
much thanks so much for the invitation
Richard and for the introduction and
great to be on the panel with Martin
then little bit a little bit later on I
think we want to go back like almost 10
years or so and for this time we've been
discussing a lot when we finally have
autonomous vehicles yes and I'm sure we
we will figure out tonight when
autonomous vehicles will come to the
market they might not be able to help
with this journey but that's just a
little bit to highlight or to visualize
I guess what Richard was just saying
from introduction were nicely done
thanks very much just a little bit of a
rundown is that my background I'm a
mechanical engineer I really got excited
about how a vehicle moves based on the
four
on the four tires so basically drive
forces braking forces and steering
forces which got me into BMW in the mid
1990s and I'm still very excited about
how a V could move
but I have to say that's not in my mind
ultimately defining the future of
mobility because it's not so much how
the vehicle moves in my mind is much
more how we get moved how we move
ourselves with vehicles or actually how
those vehicles move us therefore I
wanted a little bit more from vehicle
dynamics into mobility what I do today
and as Richard pointed out spent quite
some time here full-time at Stanford at
the Center for Automotive Research then
got into consulting where I still am
with my own consulting firm based in
Palo Alto and if they lecture at the
Stanford Business School and I was just
discussing earlier when we were walking
in here they still have to grade a few
papers tonight because at the Business
School we have these compressed
schedules where we only have the first
two weeks to teach and then two weeks
for the students to write the papers and
the papers are all about what can
incumbents do in order to remain
relevant in the automotive industry and
what can you come us do in order to get
into the automotive industry and that's
quite interesting like this rupture and
and innovators dilemma and all of these
things so all of this basically telling
you there's an engineer here speaking to
you right now but I also I guess have
gotten my fingers dirty in the business
of things and so therefore i profoundly
believe just a great engineering
solution does not make or ultimately for
market success because really there are
different things that need to come
together obviously technology and
business but also then regulation the
customer should not be forgotten and
certainly environmental concerns should
not be forgotten
many of these things we hope to actually
address and maybe ultimately solve with
autonomous driving so therefore I
thought I might talk a little bit more
about how an
autonomous vehicle might work Martin
will then give us also a lot of insights
into all the data that's being generated
and then all together all together we
will discuss what does edge computing
have to do with it a little bit about
the the autonomous car that's believe it
or not it's a slide I think I created it
maybe tell created like eight nine years
ago for my class I think it was over
there and the Earth Sciences Building
the future of the automobile and we were
discussing well how does it actually
work and so I came up with this little
animation I hope that it's still helpful
for you to understand when you get in
one of these autonomous cars you need to
tell it actually something and you
better tell it where's the destination
where do you want to go to can be a user
interface where to see the little marker
number eight where you say that's where
I want to go and then the autonomous car
basically says okay I got you on on a
map I know where we are and we basically
can be very precise with a lot of
sensors to improve our position accuracy
that we really know exactly where we are
on the planet and then we could actually
get going because we know what we want
to go to we know where we are and we
basically know what the map what the lay
of the land looks like let's plan a
route guess what problem might be there
obstacles in the route the environment
which can be other vehicles can be
pedestrians can be obstacles something
that is not in the map all of a sudden
it shows up in front of the vehicle this
is where all these sensors come in one
two and three you can see here laser
sensors cameras and radar sensors this
is where Martin I believe will have
quite some and said how much data they
actually generate what we will then have
a discussion where should we process all
this data but what we actually do know
that we figured out I know where I am
I know basically what the routes are and
now I know where we're going to go to
but there's an obstacle now we can
actually get a little bit more reactive
about our routing and plan
maneuver like you I actually need to go
around this obstacle and then maybe even
get somewhat tactical what is the actual
path is it like do you want to cut the
corner a little bit or do I want to
swing a little bit wider because it's a
pedestrian or bicyclist where I don't
want to get too close and so we get
these different steps and then we're
almost done this is now later part where
my heart actually is like the four
forces on the tires you apply basically
turning through the steering system
deceleration with the brakes and
acceleration with by wire system that
doesn't really matter technically
actually if it's an electric car or a
combustion engine gasoline powered
vehicle today everything is
computer-controlled in the vehicles and
you can just command I need one hundred
and fifty Newton meters now and you
basically get it a little bit faster
from an electric engine or electric
motor than from a combustion but stuff
but let's not forget you also want to
share some information as much as the
person in the vehicle who's no longer
the driver but the personal vehicle
needs to enter his or her destination of
choice
you ought to need to reply back yes we
will get there in 26 minutes and you
might also need to communicate even more
you know what we have to slow down a
little bit because there's challenging
traffic situation here which is what
also quite some research here on
Stanford campus has happened so that's
basically how an autonomous car works
you can cluster all these things a
little bit further and also throw a few
company logos onto here who's actually
in this field and if you look at it for
one okay we can talk about these three
categories and we will but you don't see
any car company you don't see your GM
you don't see a Ford you don't see a BMW
my former employer
Toyota's not on there and that's not
that they would not matter it's a little
bit too obvious but therefore one should
stated even more what this becomes now
is really like a lot of new technology
that we need
to integrate into probably existing
vehicles some ought to say yeah you know
what know that we get an autonomous car
and no one actually is gonna be in there
and driving anymore let's start really
from scratch and there are quite a few
companies here zooks I think should be
pointed out new row which is more the
delivery vehicle let's say you know what
we are not just going from automobile
1.0 to 2.0 we're really reinventing
mobility and that should probably not be
within the existing thinking what an
automobile is so they're they're these
companies that say okay autonomous
vehicle in a completely new shell and
maybe even completely new business model
but then there are these companies that
may be a little bit better known Aurora
is being talked about a lot too simple
is building autonomous driving stack as
it's called for trucks drive a I got a
little bit quieter out of Stanford or
the Stanford graduates out of the CS
program started that company that got
acquired by Apple over summer pony door
AI is talked about a lot and a few
others here as well so these are those
who basically say we mostly focus on
software what does it actually mean if
we say okay we do a path planning we do
a maneuver we do some more technical
driving strategies if you will that all
happens in here talk about the full
vehicle let's talk about perception
that's obviously by and large the
largest group here and and that is
somewhat indicative I guess off of the
action
maybe of the investment as well that
goes into it
there's a lot here in in lidar which is
again laser sensing we're valid eyeing
quanta G black more companies that are
talked about a lot but just don't be
don't be deceived here they are what is
that like 7/8 logos on there like people
who do this for a living who scan the
market what's going on in
startup land and technology innovators
they are tracking close to 100 lidar
companies it's lighter companies just by
itself about 100 and I'm not saying that
that's exhaustive I don't have that
spreadsheet but someone was telling me
already three years ago no we're looking
at 775 and then someone said no we look
more like 90 so it must be about 100
plus or minus in this field camera and
computer vision one company that is
maybe missing here is mobile I not sure
if we have them anywhere else but that's
basically where people say you know what
we do all of this with cameras because
cameras actually the only ones that can
detect a traffic light because the laser
beam cannot really tell if that's green
or red and won't once we get to radar
down here radar can also not detect
there's a traffic light green or red but
I assume all of you will agree it
actually does matter a lot of a traffic
light is green or red so therefore a lot
of working cameras as well
radar middle wave actually just a
stone's throw here from campus and
there's a lot of work here and in the
local Bay Area as well there are
obviously others and you might ask well
what now I get the camera idea but laser
and radar isn't that all a little bit
overkill maybe yes maybe no this is
where a lot of the discussion is still
happening what actually do we need in
order to detect a person person to
detect person a camera might be good but
then you don't really know what exactly
is the person doing so if you really
want to see if the person is walking or
maybe just standing you actually might
need to detect the extremities and say
well that's an arm and the arm goes like
this probably the person is walking you
might even need to believe it or not
detect where the person's nose is which
sounds like a really smell are you're
not getting carried away you but if you
think about it I'm a pedestrian this is
the curb side this is where the
autonomous car comes okay it makes a big
difference if I'm standing
this or like this and waving to Martin
because s I'm waving tomorrow it's
unlikely that I walk like this right but
if I stand like this very likely it
would step into the street and it tells
us something what we are about to do
here as we want to get these
self-driving cars what they are called
quite often as well if we want to insert
these self-driving cars and the traffic
as we know it it needs to get all these
little cues it might even be something
and I'm not making this up
maybe the sports called maybe that says
something because if that's made sports
go maybe with a logo on there and there
are five other people with the same
sports coding logo very likely they
belong to them if the fact we will same
sports code on the other side of the
road very likely I belong to them they
don't want to interact with them this is
how we drive and that's what we need to
get into the system and this is where we
can say yeah that is great in order to
see color and maybe get an idea what is
that object all about this is a lot
about the geometry where we say
extremities and all of that exactly how
big something is but guess what same as
our eyes don't work very well in bad
weather condition same as cameras and
lighter doesn't work too well very heavy
rains snowfall and the like this is
where radars very good so which is why
many people say you know we need this
sense of fusion we really need to make
sure that we can safely detect what it
is that we're looking at then there's
other them don't want to go too much in
detail
simulation is a pretty big topic because
we're saying how many miles do we need
to drive in order to say no it's safe
enough big debate no answer yet some
people say for a number of reasons
hundred million miles you need to drive
in order to say no it's safe enough
others say and I would agree with them
even hundred million miles are not
enough how long might it take to drive
hundred million miles you say you might
have a fleet of 100 we could but still
driving a million miles it takes a long
time
so therefore simulation is very poor
here and then v2x systems this is them
what we're getting into what we will
discuss here a little bit later or two
through Martin's presentation vehicle to
X vehicle to everything else so that's
all connectivity like how do you get
data to and from this autonomous car
localization that's something that I had
on the previous slide wherever and
relatively briefly over the map but the
map is not just a map it's not just a
map like okay there's like a two-lane
highway that basically goes from
whatever San Jose to San Francisco and
you're on it or not it's much more what
exactly is the curvature of this highway
it's exactly where said even a tree
where was a building because if I see
this tree I know well that thing at
least is not going to move which
actually does make a difference because
in challenging conditions a tree this
may be this tall it's not very different
from a person in one of these perception
systems so therefore as much as you can
tell this is a stationary object that
does not move it's very important to
know there for localization and maps are
really important and even the position a
precision that we need for localization
is very important today standard GPS
gets you won't say about 30 maybe 15
feet on our own on a good day of
accuracy that it's not enough to have a
self-driving car because you really need
to know which lane are you in on the
road because you can still have
something like with your but your camera
you know if you are in between like the
lane markings and everything but you
also need to know okay I am in this Lane
that's actually the lane that takes a
left turn it's not the lane that goes
straight because it does make a big
difference so all of this we need to
know and I think I will come to a close
here pretty soon because timing is of
essence here we definitely want to
reserve enough time for your questions
as well
but I want to close then with one thing
which I created because I got upset when
people say oh you know what the car
would just be a computer on wheels
like you really don't know anything
because a car today is about 100
computers and sensors on wheels are
ready so everything that you see here
you can read for yourself like
transmission engine surroundings weather
driver input all of that is already
computer controlled this is connected by
I think the number someone on you up to
20 communication networks within the
vehicle which is where I say well you
know what I got into the automotive
industry is in mechanical engineer
thinking that I can really define what a
car is so can I mean mechanical
engineering is still very important but
there's so much computer controlled
already in the vehicle which adds to the
complexity where today if an automobile
company launches a new car mastering
that complexity really becomes the
challenge and ultimately define success
for you often but it also tells us
that's all this information that's
already in there and the vehicle like if
someone sits on the seat or not or what
the temperature setting is like door
locks and everything so on the steering
wheel and brake application and all of
that and into this architecture we now
need to integrate the autonomous car
which might evolve out of this so that's
one direction that's a more an
evolutionary approach which is what we
discussed in length in my class at the
Business School or it might be a
disruptive or revolutionary approach
where we say you know what let's do away
with all of this let's build like an
autonomous car from scratch what we saw
in the previous slide there companies
that have this belief I cannot say that
they are wrong but building an entire
car from scratch without much experience
should not be underestimated so we shall
see but one thing is for sure these
cameras and radar and lidar and
existing in the car generates a lot of
data and thinks that's what Martin which
has a little more about what's that so
that's great spin thank good you up then
while we're changing machines yes I
asked you kind of one follow-up of
course you may so in terms of sort of
technology developments the really
recent thing one of the questions I'm
curious about this last slide you showed
about the you know incredible computer
systems plural in a car all the wires do
you see movement to make the inside of
the car wireless no not too much and I
don't want to sound like someone who
said yeah tried that didn't work but
still a little bit of inside baseball it
was one of the projects that I got a BMW
yeah 2003 or someone like yeah and so
wireless sensor networks on a car it
doesn't really apply that much because
in the car you basically know exactly
where a sensor is yeah it's exactly on
the top of the vehicle and it scans the
environment it's gonna sit there for the
life of the car and it certainly needs
power and so why would wirelessly to
have problems with something Wireless I
mean well Wireless applies our tires
because they obviously spin and so then
this is where it applies also for
testing or something like this so we did
say you know what someone brings the
vehicle into a workshop and it in a
dealership something rattles and
screeches and it's not right on my con
it's only Thursday morning so I don't
know okay we get your wireless sensor
kit just to check it out and then we do
a little bit like the 24 hour what is
that heart rate monitor awesome okay so
I'm good well she had me sit down yes
Martin the floor is yours
afternoon still I'm Martin sir house
Richard did a wonderful introduction I
don't know if there's anything more I
need to say like Richard said I run the
research at at the Alliance Research
Center we started as the Nissan Research
Center but as you all know Nissan is an
alliance with Renault and which BC so we
are like an alliance center now
that means that we work for all
companies in the Alliance my startup is
in healthcare so completely different
but also about autonomy so anybody
interested in that I'm not talking about
that but you can ask me questions later
on let me start with asking how many
people you know son gave kind of like an
overview of autonomous vehicle how many
people really know the technical
insights of an autonomous vehicle okay
so it's still a lot of people that don't
so you know because I don't want to
overwhelm you with with technology and
you know oh details so so I just wanted
to see where shall I stay and my
discussions so I titled my you know my
talk autonomous systems with
human-in-the-loop because this is my
this is the peppy for me like Richard
said I worked at NASA for more than
twelve years as a senior scientist and
one of the things that I learned there
is there you know I I have said show me
an autonomous system without a human in
the loop and I'll show you a useless
system right what is useless a useless
system a system that is useless and you
know I had debates with our scientists
at Ames early in the or in the late
1990s about autonomous spacecraft and so
you know it was obvious that it was
easier if we just take the human out of
the loop right and I said ok so now your
spacecraft grows to the edge of the
universe and then what oh no it's going
to communicate information back and I'm
like well there's a human then right so
if you don't have a human in there why
are you sending the spacecraft so the
same thing I say with autonomous systems
here on earth
right and discounts for autonomous
vehicles it's you know accounts for any
autonomy that you have there was always
a human in the loop and this to me is a
very important aspect to keep in mind
when when we talk about autonomy and
autonomous systems on you know driving
around I mean I always say how
we imagine to have millions of
autonomous vehicles driving around on
the road without humans in the loop we
have well in the United States airspace
about 6,000 airplanes in the sky at one
time and we have air traffic controllers
talk well with two pilots in the cockpit
mind you and we have air traffic
controllers talking to the pilots all
the time right why do we think we can
have millions of autonomous vehicles
driving around
nobody needs to interact with them okay
so so that's my start and then I say the
role of edge and cloud computing and and
we'll get to that why but one of the you
know just as a start one of the things
is that humans are not just in the car
all right
most of the humans are not in the car
and so we need to be able to communicate
and interact with humans not in the car
and as men was saying you know v2x so
communicating communicating from the
vehicle to outside is a very important
part of building autonomous vehicles and
we'll talk about that so the
human-in-the-loop why do we do this why
do I say that and it's because of this
slide right this is our vision it's
about what I call socially acceptable
autonomy right if I build autonomous
system that nobody likes and we have
millions of them driving on the road
that's not going to create a nice
environment right and so now of course
we can debate but what does it mean to
be socially acceptable I don't want to
go into that today but I just want you
to see that what we say it's an equation
you know it's about human and robot
teammate this is what we're talking
about this is you know the robot needs
to be interacting with humans to do that
we need AI everybody agrees with that
but we've a AI that can explain what
it's doing to humans right otherwise
we're gonna get all kinds of problems in
another talk I gave recently I talked
about the 737 max accident in the
cockpit that's an example of what
problems you get when a I can't explain
itself right
and to be socially acceptable we have we
need social science to understand how
humans behave in order for the vehicle
involved for autonomy systems to
understand how humans how to interact
with humans so this to me is really what
it's all about
to develop vehicles that are socially
acceptable we need to have explainable
AI and we need to be able to understand
humans and so people from the social
sciences are very important to
understand that let me give you a little
video for those who know autonomous
vehicles can understand why I'm showing
this vehicle for those who don't I
I just put yourself into as the driver
into this vehicle that you see you see
an image coming from the front of our
autonomous vehicle in Mountain View and
this video is meant to show how what we
call level 4 and level 5 autonomy which
is fully autonomous systems are so
incredibly difficult so this is a
intersection in Castro Street what we
see here is the traffic lights are
flickering right you see this truck
right the truck is going and you see all
kinds of construction going on we've
already given up driving in autonomous
mode by now alright and you understand
this now we just watch this scene right
this car is coming here right the car
doesn't know what to do people are
walking around stops in the middle of
the road that you know that backhoe is I
don't know what it's doing this card up
this car just goes whoa all right
his bicyclist you know now you think
okay now I'm gonna go oops that car is
just taking her left-hand turn suddenly
and so he goes now watch the guy there
on the side right you think he's taking
away counts or he's replacing cones and
then boom he just crosses the road Hey
ha well since there was a human driving
so yes can I have my water yeah yeah so
there ain't no autonomous vehicle in the
world that can do this ok let me just
say that it doesn't exist anybody who
tells you that we can do this is just
you know this we cannot do this today
no company nobody
so that just to set the level of where
we are with autonomy right and and how
difficult this is and this is just a
Wednesday morning in in Mountain View
right this is still in San Francisco you
know this is not Tokyo this is just
Mountain View little little Mountain
View all right so what is what is it
about the future right where we want to
go and I you know we say like it's the
future of connected and autonomous
vehicles because we're not going to do
boom tomorrow everybody drives
autonomous so we're gonna have connected
vehicles and autonomous vehicles and its
really to design a world of connected
and autonomous vehicles with onboard and
off-board intelligence right so the
intelligence cannot just live on board
the vehicle right to solve this problem
of this intersection we need to know
that there is construction there we need
to know that the traffic lights aren't
working right that we should not expect
that there is the normal rules of the
road that are going we need that
information from somewhere that is
intelligence that is not on board so
what it's really about is this is the
intelligence on board what sin was
talking about what I say is we need
intelligence in the cloud to communicate
information about the state of the world
and about issues that the car you know
faces from humans in a control center we
need to be able to connect to humans and
traffic management center
maybe there is a traffic management
center for the Bay Area doesn't exist
all right you know Palo Alto has a
little bit of some traffic lights that
are controlled with us you know then we
have Mountain View that has their own
little thing and then Sunnyvale has
something do you think they talk to each
other now doesn't talk to each other
right where we go actually to do
research about traffic management
centers we go to Europe you know Europe
has a way better system you know that
for instance the country in the
Netherlands has somewhere in one
province about the size of the Bay Area
there's somewhere around 1500 traffic
lights they're all connected right there
all this this is all this all works they
have you know information coming we can
get the data here no not so much so but
we meet that and then we get to smart
cities all right we need infrastructures
would be nice if we would have a lidar
on the intersection that we just look to
you know saw the video from so we can
get information from that intersection
about the objects about the backhoe that
was there you know about the cones that
were on there really nice if we would
have that information off the vehicle
for a couple of reasons the vehicle
could have known that before it went to
the intersection and decided like maybe
not such a good idea to go there
maybe I should reroute myself or it
could be that oh maybe I don't need that
expensive lighter on the vehicle anymore
the infrastructure provided information
there for my vehicle becomes cheaper
right so this is the game that we need
to play but it's really about sharing
the intelligences in these systems and
as they already say we don't have this
in the Bay Area right how long is it
going to take before we have this in the
Bay Area well I'll probably you know be
in a wheelchair that this autonomous by
it by the time we have that so it's
gonna be a while before we have that so
it's going to be piecemeal but this is
what we're after and this is where I
want to go with the next thing the the
next slide is to show you as I already
showed you in the video we can't handle
every situation
but we still want a font on his vehicle
before the AI is smart enough to handle
those kind of situations so how do we do
this in the next five years right I say
we need human intelligence and let me
show you an example of what I mean what
you're going to see is the car streaming
all its sensor data to the cloud in real
time and I say to the edge right because
time delay is really now starts to
become an issue here so we've worked
with NASA Ames to develop a system to
interface interact with the car in a way
that NASA interacts with robots on Mars
and want one thing - one thing to think
about what we're not doing what can't
you do with interacting with a robot on
Mars anybody any clue I mean then we
yeah you can't drive the vehicle in
real-time okay I can't sit in my living
room here and steer and give gas and
thirty minutes later on Mars
the rover receives my command and does
something the time delay is is similar
it's just too long so that's not how
we're driving vehicles right it's very
dangerous in my opinion to drive
vehicles remotely right if we already
have 3,400
well how many thirty four thousand
deaths in the United States by people
inside the car you know how many that's
what we have we put people somewhere
else right that's not the solution so we
don't drive the vehicle remotely what we
do is we observe what the vehicle does
and we give direction to the vehicle we
give commands and then the vehicle can
autonomously execute those commands we
say we give the vehicle go/no-go
decisions all right that's what the
human intelligence is so let me show you
an example of how that looks so here you
see half the screen this is our an image
of the car driving you see that the
vehicle has noticed an obstruction
the road it sends information it now
streams in real-time its lidar it's it's
cameras to the person and it says here I
want to go around this vehicle there's
like if you look here there's two cars
parked and somebody walking you know
working there there's a double yellow
line that means you can go around it
because that's not allowed
so do we allow autonomous vehicles to
just go around whenever they want over a
double yellow line no so what do we need
we need a human to give a go/no-go
decision and let me just show you how
that works so I think I jumped so here
there isn't the user says authorized it
sends it to the vehicle the vehicle
plants around around it and it goes so
this is a very good point so if we now I
need one human for one car we haven't
one very much all right so this is this
is then we might as well have the human
in the car so that's not what we're
proposing what we're proposing is
something like this just like air
traffic control or most of you probably
don't realize if you take the bus in San
Francisco for every four buses there is
a controller in a control room somewhere
continuously talking to all the bus
drivers to make sure that oh the
passenger just got sick in the bus what
do I do
oh I can't get to the bus stop what do I
do right there is continuous
communication between bus drivers and a
control center this is a similar idea
right is that we would have a control
center with a person maybe controlling
well what we hope at least a hundred
vehicles right so you know so the game
is really how can we get this this work
system as I call it between vehicles and
control center how can we make that as
efficient so you need as few people to
manage vehicles a fleet of vehicles on
the road just like we do with airplanes
so well we can discuss that in our panel
now hold your hold your thought you know
but this is one concept that we have
developed and we're working on and we
call this a mobility manager and it's
personnel responsible for safe and
orderly and expeditious flow of robot
fleets in the global traffic system all
right so to do that what do we need
right we need both for autonomous
vehicles and for connected vehicles an
etch right if we want to have fast
communication be nice if we have 5g
today we don't have 5g so we need to do
this over 4G which makes remote driving
even more dangerous but so we need pipes
going to the cloud where there is AI and
analytics that can take all the video
and all the information from all the
cars streaming their sensor data we can
learn from that sensor data we want to
be able to go from vehicle to
infrastructure so vehicle to vehicle
vehicle to you know traffic lights to
pedestrians right if you have a cell
phone and you send GPS be nice if I can
use that GPS to know where you are just
like Sam was saying and maybe predict
where you might be going sharing of data
with other businesses the mobility
sensor the center and and connected
vehicles we don't leave alone
so this is kind of the architecture that
we need to develop and create and this
is where H computing becomes very
valuable because if I need to have my
mobility Center you know for San
Francisco and the cloud where the
computers run are somewhere in New York
that time delay alone to send the data
from the car to New York and back over
the Internet to my car might be too long
so maybe we want an etch right in the
San Francisco Bay Area for the Mobility
Center
of the San Francisco Bay Area if I want
to do fast processing of images from my
vehicle right I might want to have it
very close in the intersection so maybe
there is an edge in the intersection to
make an intersection smart for me to
communicate that way so this is where we
are really starting to think about how
does this architecture of computing
communications and intelligence where
does the intelligent live see it in in
essence right what I what I always say
is like look do we really want a million
of data centers driving around you know
do we all need to see the same data you
know if I have 15 cars in an
intersection they all process the same
intersection data is that really what we
want is that really efficient they all
need the same computers they all process
the same images that seems inefficient
to me that processing should be done
somewhere else right that shouldn't be
done on the cloud on the car all right
so one of the reasons I say that is
because of the following so this is kind
of the same picture that van has so
these are is the car with its sensors it
has Ken data can Ken bus is one of those
networks that send was talking about in
the car it has sensor data from these
sensors it goes through the autonomous
system this is a high level picture of
an autonomous system we have sensing
with perception we have the world model
which are all the objects that we see in
the world we know what where we are
ourselves we have the map we have
decision-making we have control
we have IO to store this data in the
cloud right and here are here are all
the sensors and the canvas that generate
data so how much data is generated so
this is my back-of-the-envelope
calculation of one of our vehicles at
Nissan right we have 15 cameras we have
to light ours with one radar we have one
GPS and we have a canvas and total it
generates 140 point 2 megabytes per
second
okay so then I did some calculation so
that means in one minute driving it
generates 10 gigabytes that means in 10
minutes driving generates hundred
gigabytes in an hour driving 500
gigabytes
if 24 hours driving 12 terabytes of data
right so then I did some more
calculation I said okay what does Google
Amazon Microsoft and Facebook have they
have total of today they say 1.2 million
terabytes or 1.2 petabytes a hundred
thousand a vs will generate that in 24
hours okay so 100 AVS will generate as
much data as Google Amazon Microsoft and
Facebook have today together sorry I did
some more calculations for you so there
are 264 million vehicles in the u.s.
today
that's 330 168 Google Amazon Microsoft
Facebook's worth of data every 24 hour
alright so I hope the edge is a big edge
[Laughter]
24 hours is one day yes on Mars it's 24
hours and 37 minutes
yes in one day now I mean not every
piece of data we need to save not every
piece of data we want you know so I'm
not gonna argue here that this is all
data we need to store in the cloud of
course not I mean that's not I mean that
would be impossible right but I just
even if I cut 50% even if I cut 20% even
if it's just 10% of this number it's
still a lot of data right I mean and we
need to use that data to learn we need
to store it we need to send it
communicate it it's a lot so my last
slide is not to scare you completely if
I've not scared you enough
white it's just this number of all these
Google's together so not to scare you
even more but I hope that somebody is
thinking about privacy and security of
all this data I use this this paper by
bloom at all about privacy and security
at the usenix conference in 2017
so basically we're building data sensors
with cameras and sensors that drive
around our city and we will have every
image that you can imagine from
everybody in the city walking around
driving around doing whatever they want
to do as part of those you know the
terabytes of data we we capture and
there's fourth you know these aspects of
privacy invasive technologies right that
the security industry has known for a
long time right it's ubiquitous capture
of data in public right that's what
we're doing it's physical surveillance
by a privately owned company if this
data is stored somewhere that is owned
by a company the abilities scale without
additional infrastructure right I just
add another car and I have more data
right I don't want to have a negative
view here but if you know if some
organization says I want data they just
buy a number of autonomous vehicles
don't let them drive around I have all
the data they want for a particular
situation right difficult of notice and
choice about data practices for physical
sensors that capture data about non
users you as a pedestrian have no choice
right but to be filmed by the autonomous
vehicle right these are things we should
call you know
comparisons are of course CCTVs dashcams
Google Streetview these are all
technologies that we are developing as a
society that capture data about you as
an individual and what we need is
privacy standards and regulations but of
course technology always outpaces that
right so there is a habituation to lack
of privacy that's going on today in
society and one can wonder if that's
good or bad I don't want to say anything
you know which side you want to lean on
this is something that we as a society
in the world need to grapple with and
need to deal with but fair information
and privacy practices I think we really
need to think about and if we think
about edge computing right if we think
about 5g and etch computing the amount
of data that can be stored and can be
communicated within you know seconds is
enormous and so it's not just autonomous
vehicles that have this issue it's going
to be everything that we're going to
develop from in the home to on the
street to infrastructure to autonomous
vehicles okay that's it why don't you
take the seat closest to the stage I'm
going to start off by asking you a
question to both of our panelists and it
kind of comes in to the whole incumbents
versus newcomers things so up until now
the automobile companies have each
individually kept extremely tight
controls over anything needed to
interface into their car systems and
just last summer Baidu announced that
they were going to create an operating
system for autonomous vehicles they call
it Apollo and I'm curious how you see
the whole idea the third-party operating
system working will this change the
relationship between incumbents and
newcomers and specifically Martin how do
you see
operating system cause I know some of
the Chinese companies have been using it
was a by using it outside of China so
you go first
Apollo yeah yeah that's Baidu Apollo and
there's also some sort of a competitor
which is called Auto ware which is
Foundation and that much I understand is
an open-source project now where's that
from that's the foundation is based in
Japan okay but it's an international
global consortium I feel okay and
remains to be seen who's gonna win both
the pluses and minuses as always but to
your question is there gonna be a
universal operating system for these
autonomous vehicles maybe let me peel
the onion a little bit what what Martin
was showing it so long anymore but
what's running the canvass that was
pushed largely by an automobile supplier
bar mm-hmm back in the 1980s I believe
because it was realized you know what
we're putting in electronic fuel
injection and we're putting in brake
controllers ABS and the lights and all
of these need to work together somehow
let's implement can controller area
network not quite an operating system
but also an architecture and so it's not
completely new to the industry it
obviously it bares the question what
consultants and always gets excited
about who's holding the control point
yeah right so who's in control of things
it is definitely safe to say that the
automotive industry and the the the the
balance of power shifting mm-hmm I do
not think that it's going some sort of
black or white there's new players there
will be laggards who are not getting the
message and therefore falling behind
definitely Chinese companies I think
have a very strong play in this it is
for one because they are extremely
talented skillful and ambitious
researchers and industry engineers and
business people at play and I'm sure
that in this seminar you've also been
discussed
politics across the Pacific so it is
pointed out as one of the key objectives
to really exercise leadership in a key
industry and the automotive industry is
seen as one so it's a pretty long answer
it's not razor sharp I do realize this
but there's gonna be some sort of a
standard evolving that will need to
leave some flexibility for a volume
product versus like a high-end maybe
premium product and China is definitely
yeah when they come back to you with a
few things about the Chinese makers I
noticed that Pony da day I was one of
the ones you had on your slide Martin
first of all though how do you see the
operating system kind of from the
software side and especially open an
open API and that kind of thing yeah so
my background I don't have such a long
background in automotive industry as
Sven has you know basically Nissan
Research Center is it for me but what
I've noticed that and and rightfully so
the OEMs are incredibly safety conscious
right so everything is about safety now
from a software you know I'm more a
software guy right we all know that
software goes where we're people who use
software wanted to go and so open-source
has has proven to be a pretty efficient
way of building actually reliable
software
strangely enough everybody in the
beginning said like oh open source
software is dangerous I know at NASA
they didn't want you know I actually
have software running in Mission Control
and when we had to show what software we
had all the open source software had to
be taken out right and as researchers
you know so it's like but what we have
shown like what a model that works
really well is that the red head model
is that there will become a party that
takes this on and makes and gets all the
bugs out and
and takes this from an open source to a
supported version right that the tier
wants might be able to start using let
me ask a quick question how many people
know Red Hat yeah so so yeah so UNIX
right you know became Linux became red
you know I'd say but the tier so OMS
don't build our own software they use
the tier ones for this Oh II am sexily
don't really know how to build software
so and the you know we're not worried
with that one yeah but well I would even
make a stronger statement the tier ones
don't really know how to build software
because they are you know car makers
they you know yes they know how to build
embedded software but autonomy software
is not something you know they don't
have like a whole bunch of AI people I
know you know so now that matters why we
see all the startup companies on yes so
I could see a model where an open source
stack will become a supported stack by a
player that then is delivered to tier
ones and then use that to build
components and systems for the OEMs so
if you ask me that that I see as the
model that will that that could happen
well I'm gonna cut to the chase
do you see China going in a different
direction than the rest of the world or
the US central direction than the rest
of the world you asking me there ya know
I I think I mean again this is just my
opinion I think China has even less
regulation or more regulation depending
on how you look but it's easier in China
to get technology into place and they
will run into this brick wall right
where it's just as hard in China as it
is here and so you know I I just see I
see a similar kind of similar evolution
yeah people will realize you know all
these startups in China will realize
that it's really hard ok well let's go
let's go to audience questions go ahead
your first I saw you first if you're
about open sores then again and again
you see that borders are less relevant
whatever technology you choose in open
source you see collaborations Korea
China everywhere so decisions from
business point of view if they're going
for open source once they do that they
kind of yeah the open source is one
thing I have to say that this is
something that is very likely to be
considered you'll use technology and so
you're going to run into all problems of
export controls and all the problems
with sophia's you know being in charge
of what kind of foreign investments a
company can take your point is really
well taken but this is why we're living
in kind of a messy world right I want to
give the floor
who is a managing director for all the
tech ventures
you have a comment question from the
investor perspective anyway okay all
right we'll let you lay said we have a
couple of portfolio companies from you
in this map eponymous world so how do
you see the evolution of perception
versus computer or sensors versus brain
and so my analogy is as we're evolving
historically you have two different
paths you can invest in sensors and
therefore we have pulse and we have bats
and they have different modalities
beyond what we can do where you can
investment brings and get relatively
narrow eyes in conference say that the
weakness or constraints of perception by
the compute models and what we can run
in a corpus and so clearly all the
biological animals have constraints
whether its energy budget for budget
size in out warning of constraint over
you get a power energy cause everything
else but how do you see the trade-offs
between getting your input having more
compute power and you project five ten
years from now what those trade-offs are
going to be and how they and
configuration will evolve
okay let's spin that question first okay
so as a quick answer I would pick the
brain because the the census of the eyes
and ears and tactile senses of the car
if you will in my mind already very
well-developed because you can actually
detect an object over a pretty long
distance in pretty bad weather
conditions and even if you say you drive
out of a tunnel and there's light coming
directly into the tunnel from the Sun
that's setting right in that direction
I'm like it so that works relatively
well what does not work well at this
point is really to detect safely enough
what is it that I'm looking at
and even more so what is this thing
gonna do within the next five seconds
because it's not enough to say it's a
person the examples that I gave seemed
maybe a little bit jokingly but it
actually wasn't is that person gonna
cross the street but at that point I
know already that it is a person I know
it because the sensors are pretty good
so therefore I think it has to be the
brain and then therefore for a number of
reasons
I guess artificial intelligence is being
applied to a large extent to this I I
expect that the pendulum might swing a
little bit back again because some seem
to be relying a little bit too much on
artificial intelligence and there was
two Martin's pointed that he brought up
like explainable artificial intelligence
but a thing in the end I would pick the
brain because the rest is already very
well developed I would say if I can push
that one Martin if you're going to
comment on that
what about redundancy among the center
so yes I was actually gonna go I you
know it's a different talk but I have a
whole talk about resilient autonomous
systems and I say we don't even know how
to build resilient systems let alone
resilient autonomous systems so so I say
as an answer to your question I said
today and over the next couple of years
sensors are actually not the most
expensive part of an autonomous vehicles
it's gonna be the computer and it's
going to be the software and the calf
you that's gonna be 80% of the cost of
the system and I say why the heck do we
need to have all this compute on the
vehicle if we have the edge and we have
5g get as much as you can off the SIS
off the vehicle into the cloud into the
edge software becomes a lot cheaper you
can share the decision-making between a
number of vehicles what needs to be on
the vehicle is safety the job of the
autonomous system on the vehicle is to
provide safety in all situations right
and that is where perception then
becomes so so from the perception stack
so sensing you know the sensor alone is
not enough you need percept
which is part of the brain but it's not
the entire brain right the perception
needs to understand and so you want to
predict so I say anything that is below
a second needs to be on the vehicle any
decision you can make more than a second
the way you can do off the vehicle
right and that's how I see the system
evolving that's how I would design the
future where I have thousands of
autonomous vehicles in a fleet I would
want to have one decision-making module
in the cloud that does the
decision-making for all thousand
vehicles and not all vehicles by
themselves doing their own but that then
becomes a problem so you have to so
there are different ideas in a multi
agent peer-to-peer kind of system you
say let's each agent decide by
themselves they communicate and they can
optimize or you say do we have a shared
and we have kind of like a central
control system that that that does this
and it depends on the application if I
have a Robo taxi company I probably want
that central control system that does
the decision-making for all my vehicles
and my vehicles just keep safe that's
hard to manage
we've gotta let you do your second
question go ahead so I don't want to go
too - six - six - six and all other
standards which define safety but but
the question is we are interested so
think about evolution for machine vision
- deep neural Nets and so how we're
moving from human pre-trained or
predefined features into the world where
the machine finds its own variables and
random neural net on whatever the
mission really is important for physical
vision and so think about chess problems
like people writing chess programs
assigning human weights and then you let
alpha go to whatever alphago deed and
then eventually kind of more deep
learning methods and so you see pretty
drastic improvement in performance from
systems program and comprehensible by
human beings to the system which we
don't know how to work we know inputs
but then it does something which we
cannot explain and understand it just
test them and does really well and so
the question is I understand from safety
and security and an automotive
perspective you want to have
comprehensible systems in terms of
performance there is a strong argument
to say if you don't constrain the
problem by it must be comprehensible you
can evolve using implement better
solution to the problem to the step and
so how do you see do seats company in
some countries say China will say you
know what I don't care if it's
comprehensible of not I just measured
the final output of the system if it
doesn't kill people and find what it why
doesn't people kill people I don't know
and you go to Germany will say no no I
want to get back to back and web slice
you will Nets
partition it and say this is where my
problem is coming from so how do you see
that the difference in philosophies and
evolution based on your regulations and
sector claims Martin I think that one's
for you so you know it's not only I
think it's more about philosophy of how
you develop you know resilient systems
and and so the thing so my personal view
you know as I said if we cannot even
build a 737 with an autonomous system
for the pilot that doesn't crash after
40 years of trying right why do we think
that we can do this so you know with
autonomous vehicles without edge cases
that are problematic and it's win these
edge cases where the you know the the
explained ability needs to come in and
so if everything goes fine yeah I don't
need explainin ability if I don't need
to explain myself to the pedestrian if
you saw in my example when the car needs
to go across the double yellow line and
the rule is of the road is that you're
not allowed to cross the double yellow
line and so therefore we say from the
regulation point of view that the car
needs to now have a human intervention
this is a human break the law right go
go right at that point the human wants
to know why are you asking me this
question right what what is it that you
want me to do so the so the AI goes from
being able to go around the car to
explaining why it can't go around the
car to the human and so from those types
of systems we need explain why I and
your deep neural net will not be able to
do that very well in the in the near
future but if you never get into this
problem so if you have a society where
it is okay to go then
yeah we never need to explain then maybe
you're right and and what is the right
answer I think depends on the philosophy
you want to take about safety and the
philosophy you want to take about do we
want socially acceptable autonomy or do
we just want to have humans adapt to
whatever autonomy we think is there
autonomy for you and that is just a
societal question now if I need to watch
out every time because I see an
autonomous vehicle I'm like what let
that thing pass before I there you know
you think that is okay then fine we can
do that but I think in the Western world
you know in certain cities like San
Francisco that's not gonna fly what's
one of caution really quickly because we
heard this example again from chess
computers and and alphago and so on and
then quite often the story goes look
they can do it in chess and to play go
why can you not just have a car drive
these incredible machines I really want
to caution everyone because of the
fundamental difference between playing
however complex board game and traffic
just on this campus and that's the
difference between a super huge number
and infinity and of course safety and
everything but even if you take go
which I have to admit I don't play go I
don't know how to play it but I know how
to play chess it's a huge number of
different variations where all the
different figures can be black and white
one but it's a finite number and it
applies fantastically well to a computer
to run probably it also interacts it
doesn't if you have a super fast
computer you can calculate all these
different variations that doesn't apply
in traffic it would only be the same
thing if the the King in on the white
field just moves just a little
millimeter to the left which might maybe
show the intent where the King might
move and then you want to calculate
orders and maybe the King's turned a
little bit if they have matters because
all this matters and driving with this
example that I gave earlier never I want
to caution a little bit it's important
to have these discussions but it only
applies to some extent okay I've seen a
number of hands but I saw yours first go
ahead like this I actually worked on
Tesla autopilot in 2016 and I'm a conf
curious what the discussion would be
like if we had someone from the cs
department here today kind of curious to
hear your thoughts on your presentation
with respect to whether use what you're
proposing is something that you believe
is fundamentally the right way for the
long term so what implementation of
self-driving cars or whether you think
that this is kind of like a stopgap
solution because you think that I guess
I general AI is kind of like long it
long enough away from where we are today
that you make sense to invest as a
business as a commercial enterprise into
a pretty huge infrastructure project I
just say you are asking me to mean what
is presented and as you say there's some
limitations like the amount of data you
need to pipe to the central command
command system and that's a lot of
infrastructure investment so that's very
first structure investment makes sense
if for example car base a I can drive in
the in five years ten years or 20
years yeah I mean that's so I think it's
a great question and I'm a very
pragmatic person so if I think if you
know the industry has kind of been
saying that we were getting autonomous
fully autonomous vehicles in the next
five years for the last 20 years
maybe generation but for the last 10
years and and we're not there and I
don't see us to be there in the next
five years maybe in in very you know
certain area is very limited you know
and and then it's gonna be you know
minimal so that's why I think it's it's
a it's a stopgap but not really because
you know my example of the 737 max you
know that after 45 years of auto pilot
in the cockpit
you know we suddenly have an incredible
you know two plane crashes that were
pretty pretty dramatic and if you look
at how these what happened you know it's
not that we don't know how to build
these systems safely we do or they do
but the pressures its organizational
pressures
Kame that made the system you know the
way it was and and the crash actually
happened so I'm just I'm just somebody
who thinks we never have autonomous
systems completely safe enough that we
don't need humans in the loop
that's just my my strong belief and if I
can if I can follow up with a question
on that though so partial autonomy has
its own dangers of course if if your car
is going to send the decision to you and
you have to react within a second and
you're kind of spaced out much less
asleep at the wheel you know isn't that
even more dangerous yeah we got a Tesla
expert few so so that's what I'm saying
it's hard right it's really hard so yeah
so so that's what my solution is a human
supervisor just like air traffic control
and you know believe me the the the
aerospace industry has been trying for
decades to try to put more autonomy in
the cockpit right and and now they're
working on free flight and you know and
they're trying to sell so what they've
done if they have said okay fly three
miles apart
you know from top to bottom and you know
so that if something goes wrong we have
time to react and so if so if we are
willing to do that on the road you know
maybe we can we can make it safer but I
don't think so other people say well let
get the damn pedestrians of the road
from you know this I saw a simulation of
MIT is like oh we just you know cars for
driving you know we don't need traffic
lights anymore and then you look at the
simulation like there's no people in the
simulation what you topia is this you
know but I mean so this is we have we
will have people on the road and so I so
I think it's going to take if we take
the step you're taking it's going to
take a long time before industry will be
willing to take the risk of putting
autonomous be fully autonomous vehicle
on the road spend comments on this you
know I really appreciate them the
question about infrastructure and my
answer is those who say
autonomous have to say infrastructure in
the same sentence otherwise I don't
think how it's gonna work
and I find it peculiar and you brought
up if we're talking from this yes the
property and I do know that computer
scientists by and large feel that it
should be all self-contained
it should be and really autonomous
system which means it doesn't need
anything else to fulfill its mission or
its tasks and everything and I
understand the appeal because
infrastructure is huge investments which
you said and and just to give some
reference 50 percent of the road
infrastructure in the United States
today is underfunded that means we have
only enough budget to fix 50% of the
bridges and to fill 50% of the potholes
and to stripe 50% of the lane markings
that need to be striped and now we're
not even talking about using any of this
communication infrastructure for Animus
vehicles and still I find it surprising
if especially computer scientists and I
will say that argue for the case of not
connecting automobiles highly safety
critical systems what we are connecting
everything else we're connecting
obviously laptops you're connecting
watches we're connecting refrigerators
we're connecting the switches to our
light in the living room and everything
is connected
but automobile would do without I'm not
quite sure if we're leading them right
discussion there and what might be part
of it and I've been thinking about this
quite a bit because autonomous driving
is such a vast topic again it's not
getting from automobile 1.0 to
automobile 2.0 we are reinventing
traffic as we know it and very often we
see the brightest minds on the planet
focusing on very specific things may be
figuring out with artificial
intelligence how I can do an unprotected
left turn or how I can do a laser
scanner that even can detect the nose in
like whatever 400 feet distance and once
we get this we say we're gonna step
forward
but we still don't know how many steps
we need to take to actually have a fully
autonomous car and the last thing I
would say to this I think it's maybe in
a picture that might resonate with the
audience
Steve flat over told me this he's from
UC Berkeley really amazing research on
the field of autonomous vehicles if you
want to go up on Mount Everest and you
are here in San Francisco Bay Area you
basically get on a plane you fly to
London you switch planes flying to
Kathmandu you get out of the airport
someone takes you to the first base camp
to go up on Mount Everest and maybe by
distance or number of steps maybe you
covered or 90 95 percent but this is
really then when the challenge begins
and this is when you figure out if you
make it or not
up there and this might be roughly where
we are maybe we made it to a second and
third base camps and I'm going to how
many they are going up on Mount Everest
but it's not linear where we say we've
come come this far therefore what you
say in five years we will be able to do
it okay I want to do one more well let
me just make one one comment quick it's
a quick comment I only know one a really
good autonomous system it's called a
human being right we don't do stuff
alone we collaborate and we communicate
in order to collaborate right so to
think that the tunneler systems are not
neat don't need to collaborate and
interact with others is just a to
monitor understanding of force thank you
one last question that's yours back in
the back no the the ethics they say more
about what came with can you expend a
little bit more on the different ethical
considerations that go into the finding
like
it's it's a big debate this this topic
of ethics for autonomous vehicles I
heard about it for the first time on say
eight or nine years ago which relatively
soon after the discussion around the
legal aspects of autonomous driving
we've got into ethics of autonomy
actually there's a this is a class here
on Stanford lectured by Professor Chris
Curtis and dr. Stevens labs and they
they lecture on the ethics of autonomous
cars and once we are there that we can
actually distinguish safely enough
between one person and another there
would be far out and I don't know if
actually how a system should make this
decision because it could still be wrong
and I've been in many discussions where
I said you know what if these are the
only two options like the eight year old
school kid or the 80 year old
grandmother by the way my mom is 80 if
you make these decisions that means you
were too fast a while ago because of
your only two options hitting to kill
someone
that means you were overestimating your
skills and handling estimating the risk
and you will kill someone and still
someone that told me what's when you are
not getting at you're an engineer you
don't understand it and there was a
philosopher PhD action in philosophy
it's important that we're having this
discussion it's not if we find a
solution
so therefore the ethics matter a lot
because now we really design systems
that will make decisions on someone's
behalf with all the consequences and
therefore we need to have the discussion
but until we get to the point that we
can differentiate between like age of a
person race probably will need to be
discussed and in spring actually there
were news on the web that these
automated vehicles cannot detect people
of color as well as they can detect
middle-aged white men
Martin any last comments well we chose
the color thing yeah so it doesn't have
to do anything with race but the outcome
so they need the ethics question you
know what none of his vehicle is just a
manifestation of today's machine
learning capability so you know ethics
are you know the problem with ethical
decisions are here today I mean if we
can distinguish a cat from a dog you
know we start having a problem if
machines can start doing that and we
need to discuss that it's not just
autonomous vehicles it you're your your
Apple camera right or your Samsung
camera will soon make these kind of
ethical decisions if we would let them
so it's really a debate that as as fen
says that is larger than just autonomous
vehicles that doesn't mean that it isn't
important that's why I had the privacy
slide on there right because if if they
become persuasive and the person from
Tesla already knows he takes camera you
know images all over the place
I mean so so companies need to have you
know I work with my startup in in
healthcare and there we have the HIPAA
you know rule right and we need to be
HIPAA compliant if we store you know
private information healthcare
information in the cloud what why don't
we have that for other stuff right I
mean so so so these are the kind of
things that I think we need to really
think about and grapple about and and
that is a societal question a legal
question and Europe is different than
the United States is different than
China I don't think this question is so
much problem in China you walk into
China and you will body B body scan
today and you know so it depends on
where where your tolerance is for for
ethics and for privacy and I think our
culture will change because of these
technologies but it's not autonomous
vehicles it's the machine learning
people you need to ask the question too
okay so we've got some refreshments
outside to encourage continuing the
conversation for a little bit please ask
your questions after that but if you
would please join me in thanking
[Applause]